what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to top 5 Tuesday a weekly
series where we count down the top 5
characters team stories and concepts
from across the comic book industry and
in this video we're going to be counting
down the top 5 non-powered Marvel
superheroes now keep in mind these are
characters with no powers in the
traditional sense meaning that telepathy
telekinesis energy projection matter
manipulation ties to mysticism and all
the derivatives of that stuff including
the Super Soldier Serum will not be
included here and so for all of you fans
of Captain America I'm sorry to say we
are not going to see him on this list
having said that let's jump into it so
starting off the list at our number 5
spot is none other than Bucky Barnes the
Winter Soldier initially introduced as
the sidekick of Captain America in
Captain America comics number one in
1941 Bucky Barnes history from the
original interpretation was actually
reckoned by Ed Brubaker and Captain
America vol 5 with a resurrection of
Bucky Barnes after his presumed death
during World War two due to Captain
America's unwillingness to kill targets
as well as engage in other unsavory
actions in a combat situation Bucky
Barnes was basically trained as a
teenager and I guess in order to be an
expert assassin he was actually
introduced to ask Captain America's
sidekick and while fighting alongside
Captain America in World War two
Bucky Barnes demonstrated a cunning mind
and a very very ruthless nature in his
willingness to basically kill enemy
soldiers with no questions asked and
when he was saved by the Russians after
his presumed death and transformed into
the Winter Soldier
his skills were multiplied several times
over which made him and almost equal to
Steve Rogers and hand-to-hand combat
speed and endurance and he even
undertook the mantle of Captain America
after the death of Steve Rogers at the
hands of agent 13 Sharon Carter so
coming in at number four is Black Widow
Natasha Romanoff and you had to know she
was going to be on this list initially
appearing in tales of suspense number 52
in 1964 Black Widow like Bucky Barnes
was trained as an expert assassin but
where Bucky Barnes was trained by
Americans first followed by the Russians
natasha romanoff was trained by the
Russians directly in the infamous Red
Room program Black Widows training
during her time in the Red Room and her
experiences with shield The Avengers and
Heroes for Hire
as well as Olivia liberators have
actually helped her to develop a mind
capable of analyzing prioritizing and
responding to multiple shield situations
simultaneously meaning at the same time
as well as being an expert in
military-grade weapons shield weapons
and alien weapons and technology in
addition to being a master in over 15
different forms of martial arts all of
which come together to make her one of
the most formidable non-powered
assassins in the world second only maybe
to the villain Elektra so rounding out
our list and the number 3 spot is my
personal favorite Frank Castle The
Punisher initially appearing an amazing
spider-man number 129 in 1974 Frank
Castle has no enhancements of any kind
to his body whatsoever
instead Frank Castle is powered for lack
of a better word by the memory of his
dead family and a subsequent desire to
kill villains anywhere and everywhere
regardless of the situation or even
their desire to atone for their actions
having previously been trained as a
member of the Marine Force Recon the
Australian SAS and even the United
States Navy SEALs Frank Castle possesses
advanced knowledge in all forms of
weapons explosive ordnance
military-grade weapons specialized
weapons stealth espionage intelligence
gathering and torture not to mention his
incredible mental resistance to pain and
his skills in hand-to-hand combat simply
speaking once Frank hassel commits to
killing a target the only thing that can
stop him is his own death coming in at
the number 2 spot on our list is none
other than Rocket Raccoon and in truth I
put him in here because I thought you
guys would love it there are better
choices besides Rocket Raccoon for the
number 2 spot but he's still pretty
formidable initially appearing in Marvel
preview number 7 but gaining popularity
with the Incredible Hulk and issue
number 271 Rocket Raccoon is a bipedal
raccoon guarding the keystone quadrant
of the Marvel Universe it actually
possesses skills and knowledge in both
earthbound and alien based martial arts
starships weapons systems and explosive
ordnance
as well as being a highly adept military
tactician and strategist able to
immediately adjust almost any situation
to his favor now coming in at the number
one spot on our list Nick Fury initially
appearing in sergeant fury and his
Howling Commandos in 1963 Nick Fury was
previously established as a soldier and
eventual spy with no real exceptional
skills beyond what we've seen in this
list so far in fact the only real
notable role that he played for the
longest time was being the director of
shield which allowed him knowledge in
various shield weapons and systems but
that was really about it
but all of this changed in the original
sin event when it was revealed that Nick
Fury had been systematically eliminating
threats to earth since the 1960s and
that to us as the reader for every
single foe that was faced by the
earthbound heroes this was simply just a
circumstance that Nick Fury couldn't
stop this was simply just an instance
where by he couldn't keep these forces
from threatening the planet Earth
furthermore Nick Fury's actions as the
man on the wall as he referred to it led
him both within the earth itself as well
as throughout the cosmos and even to
other dimensions requiring him to become
knowledgeable and Universal weapon
systems Universal starships cosmic
entities other dimensional entities
other dimensional concepts other
dimensional weapons other dimensional
starships and their entirety and in
addition all of this Nick Fury during
the original sin event was
single-handedly able to defeat a full
contingent of the Avengers by himself
led by Steve Rogers and Thor and he was
actually able to strip Thor of his
ability to wield his own hammer by
whispering something the Marvel hasn't
revealed yet so there you have it that
is my top five list so here's my
question for you guys what's your top
five give me your top five list of
superheroes and Marvel comics that have
no powers with that being said I will
catch you guys later peace